anh ạ
anh alo chào các bạn
anh Đợi mình tí Đợi mình thích
Hôm nay cuối tuần là không Hôm nay không
hẳn là cuối tuần nhiều hôm nay mình ngủ
thỉnh thoảng bọn mình mới bắt đầu Ồ dọn
dẹp nhà cửa ở
ừ ừ
à à
anh alo các bạn nghe thấy rõ alo alo
Hôm trước có bạn bảo Mic bé
là mình sang định hết cỡ
Alo đưa bạn nghe thấy rõ à
có thêm phụ đề tự động á
Ừ mình mình có mình luôn chỉnh nó phụ đề
tự động này nhỉ Mình xem lại nhé
Mình thấy ở đây có vẻ nó không thêm này
thôi lại
bình thường mà mình mình có chỉnh cài
đặt thì con nghỉ à
à à
ừ ừ
ờ ờ
Ừ ok thì bạn đang thể các bạn đang thấy
màn hình của mình về hôm nay cái thứ
mình sẽ học thuộc
như mình đã nói là
các bạn không hỏi nhiều ở trong
buổi học word trong toàn kiểm tra rồi
thành ra là cậu chẳng có câu hỏi gì cả
cũng như là những đời thường của mình
chia sẻ nhiều bạn ở đây còn đã học cả
bên quá lãi phải ra là mình chỉ mình
không muốn chia sẻ những kiểu hôm nay
mình chia sẻ xong rồi hôm west lại chia
sẻ chung
nhà mình sẽ phải chia ra là hôm nay chia
sẻ những cái gì đó mà bên web cũng chia
sẻ hơi khó
từ
hôm trước có thể các bạn thấy lúa hôm
nay nó sẽ dễ hơn rồi đi dễ hơn một tí
thôi hôm nay mình cũng sẽ không thể dạy
nó canh dễ quá được Bởi vì thực tế là
cái này mình đang dậy nó đúng kiểu định
nghĩa là chuyên sâu thì ra là kiểu chứ
thực tế thì các bạn học ở chính Trường
ấy thì người ta ngại dạy cái mức độ khó
như là nhiều thầy cô không hà nặng thích
cái này làm nên là không Chuyến sau lắm
đấy thì
các thầy cô khác chỉ việc
dạy các bạn về Kris xong rồi tên của nó
xong ngồi á xơ Begin em xong trong đấy
có thể mấy cái câu đơn giản Shake Asus
đó ngoại Thế cũng là xong được một cái
bài rồi nhưng mà như thế thì sẽ sẽ làm
cho sinh viên cảm thấy thắc mắc rất
nhiều cái cũng những cũng như là không
hiểu được thực sự là nó gì 2i
Ừ để mà dậy được hết cái hay của nó thì
bắt buộc phải dậy cả cái khó đúng ạ Thức
dậy mày đơn giản không hiểu sẽ lấy
Insert thì thì các bạn thấy không dùng
nó không dùng code không dùng phân sinh
cũng được đầu ngoan
thì bắt buộc phải dạy những cái nó
chuyên sâu tí mà càng chuyên sâu luôn
nha các bạn sẽ càng thấy nó loạn bởi vì
nó mới bởi vì thực tế Tùy các bạn đang
bảo kia là học học cái này phải ngay ba
bốn lần mấy hiểu không ạ thì đúng là như
thế bởi vì ở trên trường trên trường
mình dậy mình không phải dậy một một
buổi xong Được hẳn một cái một cái như
thế mà hôm trước mình nghe trong vòng
một tiếng đầy đúng à nhưng bằng 3 buổi
dậy trên lớp của mình là một buổi dậy
theo lớp của mình bốn điểm 4 tiếng thực
hành một tiếng lý thuyết và 3 tiếng mà
lại mình sẽ cho sinh viên mình thực hành
từ A đến Z Vì thế nên là các bạn mà lĩnh
hội kiến thức của ba buổi chỉ ra vòng
một tiếng ấy hiểu ạ nghĩa là 12 tỷ không
Đúng không cả bao gồm thực hành trong
vòng một tiếng nghe online mà các bạn
mới hiểu được hết thì các bạn chắc là
giỏi siêu nhân ấy giỏi hơn nhà mình vì
mình không thể làm được điều đấy
thế nên là mình thấy một tuần học một
buổi như thế này rất là ổn mà các bạn
làm bài tập cũng như là xem đi xem lại
cho hiểu hoa - - trên lớp của mình nào
kiểu 3 buổi cái là nó sẽ là kiểu cách
nhau cứ một ngày học một buổi Thì nghĩa
là trong vòng kiểu 556 ngày bao nhiêu
lĩnh hội từ được đấy cũng tương đương
đúng không ạ
là không Mình đã dậy gì đâu Mình đang
chỉ nói qua về cách học của cái này nó
khó à rất là khó thấy à các bạn kêu chỉ
cần hiểu cơ bản thôi cũng được hiểu tác
dụng của nó cũng được Còn nếu mà các bạn
muốn chuyên sâu Giống như mình nói thì
các bạn sẽ để phần chính sau phải học
mấy cái khó khó lắm ạ con nếu mà chuẩn
đấy thì chắc là mình sẽ phải chia lại
cái mục lục của cái video là đoạn nào sẽ
là đoạn Cơ bản nó ngoan bạn ở đoạn khó
ra đến đoạn khó mình sẽ bảo thôi Nhưng
mà mình sẽ chia thấy nó có bạn kiểu lúc
đầy ý giờ sẵn ra Tinh thần này nhảy sang
đấy một khó ngắm hoa gợi cảm thấy não ra
thực cá Thế mới gọi là học mà nó ngọn
học thì nó phải khó
Đi
học mà thấy dễ quá cậu
một cộng một bằng hai thì các bạn chẳng
cần nhớ mọi chuyện và bài học gì cả à
giới
thiệu hôm nay mình sẽ học về Phong Trần
này xong rồi Ở đây cái link này mình để
các bạn rồi không ạ cho mình cứ gõ lại à
à à
đi
học lại cơ bản lẹ không ạ khi gạch cây
lại thì chưa chắc nó nó đã cẩn Trì Nên
là các bạn cứ phải chịu khó học dần dần
dần thôi
Ừ
cái cái thời gian đầu nói chung là đối
với mình nhé Mình quan điểm là lập trình
viên mình sẽ có hai cái giai đoạn rất
khó đó đoạn đầu tiên đó là giai đoạn mới
học
Ừ thì có rất nhiều cái ấy trên mạng
Hương Trà bao nhiêu tài liệu bao nhiêu
khóa học cơ bản vân vân vân mỗi thầy cô
dạy một kiểu kiểu cảm thấy an tỷ tỷ thứ
cần phải học được hiểu là
các bạn thích heo mạng web thì phải học
một kiểu theo mạnh ứng dụng và sẽ một
kia thì mạnh ghê mình hôm kiểu
Ừ để giai đoạn và khi các bạn có gì thứ
để mà học có giai đoạn 2 nó không phải
là khi các bạn học xong hết rồi không
khi các bạn hiểu thực chất là làm không
phải tầm hợp tất cả các bạn chỉ cần học
chuyên các bạn biết được cái thứ mà mình
mình mình muốn theo rồi các bạn sẽ còn
chuyên thứ đấy thì đến giai đoạn đấy thì
lại rất ít tài liệu được các bạn thực sự
là học bởi vì còn đầy người hiểu mình
làm rồi nhưng người ta không chia sẻ
hoặc Thậm chí bạn là một trong những
người tiên phong đầu tiên làm đấy chẳng
hạn ví dụ Giả sử Hồi trước mình làm mì
tôm Facebook đấy rất nhiều cái là ở mình
mình có thể học được từ người đi trước
nhưng thực ra có nhiều cái cái nó chả
chia sẻ đâu cả mình và tự mò tất cả
những điều đấy mình cảm thấy rất nhiều
cái kiểu các bạn muốn làm nó phần mềm
kiểu chưa ai làm đúng không ạ từ kiểu
thành một doanh nhân một Bill Gates hạn
kiểu gửi hết thì
có phải là những người tiên phong đúng
không làm những người đấy thì đương
nhiên mình sẽ khó học hỏi từ nhiều người
I
Ừ
tí tí mình sẽ giải thích các bạn các bạn
sẽ thấy sự khác nhau giữa hai thằng này
ngang mặt phẳng xin với Oxy Lưu 2 tháng
ngày Nếu mà đương nhiên là với ngôn ngữ
lập trình thì cả hai thằng được tính hàm
thôi hàm hàm xong rồi truyền tham số rồi
xử lý rất thứ vân vân Nhân và đối với
FBI là tách làm hai cái một cái là cái
xử lý không Chuyển là xử lý dữ liệu và
một cái cái chỉ ra để lấy dùng lấy dữ
liệu trở về nó không có xử lý cả ừ
à à
có
phải chuyên sâu này sẽ dạy kiến thức nào
vậy ạ Thực ra thì cho là bạn không biết
được bạn theo từ buổi đầu không Nhưng mà
thực ra đây đây đây toàn bộ toàn bộ
những cái Tab ở trên này sẽ là những bạn
nhưng sẽ dạy này từ Index viewiew xong
có viết phương trình trên sân Thì cái
trang sách như mình đã nói là em mình ít
áp dụng như là
mình chưa kinh nghiệm thực tế giờ này
lắm
Mình sẽ Chị nói qua các bạn các bạn lý
thuyết cái này thì các bạn
các bạn biết thôi mà người biết thôi các
bạn không biết được về sau sẽ đưa các
bệnh lây không ạ
chỉ
có thể là hai bộ nữa sẽ hết
đấy là trong trường hợp mà mày ông theo
được cái bộ chi cơ vừa buổi trưa là khó
hơn rất nhiều hợp có khó nó khó hơn của
boot nhưng mà
sau đó thì mình sẽ cho thử làm cái câu
hỏi Vẫn đá này nghỉ rồi các bạn trả lời
mình đang nghĩ mình đang nghĩ đâu nhé là
hôm đấy sẽ có thể gọi Dung trước thử một
lần đi
gọi zoom để mà các bạn à
thì các bạn qua đấy để mà hiểu trả lời
thi vấn đáp Đóng mặc ạ
thì mình sẽ bọc tên Ngẫu nhiên Bạn ở đó
ngồi hỏi bạn đấy dài câu rồi Bạn ấy thử
bật mí trả lời cho nó vui đúng không
Cũng như là kiểu về sau là kiểu thị mình
như mình định nói thì cuối khóa của wep
thì sẽ có bảo vệ bảo vệ đồ án cũng sẽ
nhớ mà online cho cũng qua rồi mà nó bạn
thì lần này mình cứ thử trước qua dùm
cái vụ trả lời câu hỏi vẫn đánh mày đi
khi phát bằng không quan trọng về việc
bằng cấp ở đây đâu đúng ạ trường Cái này
có tính ra trường học đâu bằng gì cả à
anh nói chung ở cái này còn là yếu tố tự
tin nữa đúng không các bạn tự tin nói
trước đám đông chịu rất nhiều nhưng quan
trọng là Toàn người lạ mà mình không yêu
cầu các bạn phải mở camera thấy K thì ra
thoải mái mà đúng không ạ Các bạn cứ cứ
Chỉ việc lên tiếng trả lời
bởi vì bài toán ở đây là mình muốn rèn
các bạn về các độ tự tin nữa
tự tin phát biểu những cái thứ kiến thức
của mình à
à
thực ra thì như mình nói là sẽ có bị bên
mình đang thử nói chuyện vài bên để mà
nó có tài trợ gì đó cho sinh viên mình
đương nhiên là sẽ đổi lại là các bạn sẽ
phải làm cho bên đấy Chẳng hạn hay gì đó
đúng à Không thể người ta cho mình thứ
gì làm miễn phí được cuộc đời sáng ai
cho các bạn miễn phí đi cả Loan
Ừ thế thì đấy nghĩa là họ sẽ tài trợ cho
các bạn gần như là để mạnh các bạn phải
giờ làm cho họ mà nóng lạnh
à à
em kết bạn kia nói về axwell lồng nó
ngoan hết Kia lồng bản chất nó chính là
kiểu dạng như là sapaly đúng không Thì
thỉnh thoảng mình sẽ dạy một tí Safari ở
trong những cái bài học này tưởng như tí
mình sẽ phải tập sẽ có spree nhưng mà để
phải chuyên sâu hơn giống như là cho rất
nhiều bạn với nhau thì ở cái đấy liên
quan hệ khi âm nâng cao hơn quen sâu thì
cái này thì mình trỗi dậy các bạn tương
đối thôi chứ mình cũng không không tự
tin nói chuyện hẳn kéo quý ông nâng cao
lắm
anh nghe hài xóa ở cũng sẽ khó mà khó
khó mà có hẳn một cái khóa ép ga trên
nâng cao như thế
ờ ờ
sau cái khóa chuyên sau này thì như mình
từng nói nó sẽ là chắc là mình sẽ gặp
lại với khóa quét cơ bản tất cả mình sẽ
dạy 357 khó web cơ bản sẽ không còn lại
thêm thì với O nữa bởi vì thế này là thế
này là đủ kiến thức
thì các bạn tương đối về Apple rồi
sẽ không Không cần phải biết hên lắm cái
queo nữa mà các bạn chỉ cần biết áp dụng
và thực hành làm ra một sản phẩm mà nó
thôi
à à
ô
hay buồn nữa cho hai tuần nữa mà ngủ à
các
bạn với thể sang bên lớp quá phải học
cũng được
hình dung được cách áp dụng swar vào làm
ra một sản phẩm trong nó sẽ như thế nào
ạ
à à từ hôm trước thì thực ra ở có mình
mình tự nốt lại đấy thôi là
đó là việc là xinh thoảng Các bạn nhớ
cốt của mình thỉnh thoảng nó sẽ có vết
xong rồi Thỉnh thoảng mình phải thêm rốt
đúng không biết một cái gì đó đây đúng
không ạ sau đó thỉnh thoảng mình phải có
group Giả sử mình muốn muốn xóa nó đi để
mà tạo lại mới đúng không Đúng trước
mình mới tra được có lệnh rất là hay nó
class or play này trong một vài trường
hợp great wall in enter được
các bạn thử tra nhé or replace Word
trong đó thì
ví dụ là View được ạ Mình nhớ vui vì có
đây nhưng mà nếu là xử hôm trước mình
học ngu thì nó sẽ không có press Play mà
nó Chris bowen enter Tức là sao nghĩa là
sẽ thêm mới hoặc là thay thế cảm thấy
mình cái đấy rất hay à
à à
về
cách setup 1db đến nào cho bảo mật không
Cái này mình đã hôm trước à Buổi đầu
buổi đầu bởi Thứ hai nhớ rồi nhưng còn
nói qua các bạn về cái vụ
hát mã hóa các cột cột mật khẩu rồi Cái
đấy là liên quan đến bảo mật Tuổi đấy
còn bể thêm bảo mật thêm mình chắc là
các bạn phải áp dụng vô CPU này xong rồi
video để mà cho các lập trình viên không
bị can thiệp một cách trực tiếp vào
trong d b
à à
để
tối ưu hóa có quay đi cái này nhưng mình
vừa nói thì nó rất là nó liên quan hệ
yêu cao chuyên sâu nhằm nâng cao thì
mình mình cho mình chỉ dạy một cách vừa
đủ ở trong cái khó ai thôi chứ mình cũng
không chuyên để nó dậy các bạn với cái
đấy à
à à
thế hả bạn kia nói là biết sơ sơ HTML CS
rồi cho đỡ theo dạy xanh ra Swift học
thứ ra cũng được các bạn sẽ thỉnh thoảng
sẽ bỏ lỡ những cái chia sẻ trên diện
kiến thức khác của mình khi mình dậy Cái
đấy nữa đúng không
ừ ừ
à à
Ờ
Ờ nhưng mà vừa rồi nhận nhân tự nhân
tiện là mình à Mình có nói qua vụ là
Tuyết và kết lọ enter này đúng nghĩa là
kiểu thêm hoặc là sửa đúng hoa thì mà
bản chất là nó không có thêm sửa mà nó
sẽ là kiểm tra lại ít sĩ để kiểm tra của
quân 70 sau đó thì mình mới tạo mới nếu
mà giờ sự nó không còn bạn
ở đâu trong trường hợp này nó là tồn tại
thì xóa nó đi này sâu tạo mới đúng không
ạ nhưng mà ở đây nó bị
có bạn bình luận ở ngay dưới này
ở đó là có thể trường hợp xảy ra là khi
mà khi mà cái rốp cái dốc ở trên này gốc
ở trên này có vấn đề thì khi mà tạm mời
đấy lại nó sẽ lỗi kiểu cờ thế thành ra
cách cách hợp lý hơn đấy
đó có tạo 1 cái code trống sau đó thì
mới bắt đầu enter sửa capo trong đấy sẽ
luôn được
xe mình nghĩa là cái cách này là 100
những cái tư duy mình mình đang nói qua
về cái việc là tư duy khi mà giải quyết
một bài toán các bạn có thể xử lý bằng
nhiều cách có thể là kiểu giống như ở
đây kiểm tra có tồn tại này nếu mà không
Nếu mà có tồn tại thì xóa nó đi Xong rồi
tạm mới thì thì có thể nó sẽ lỗi còn ở
đây kiểm tra tội có nôn tại không tồn
tại thì nó mới tạo và mình sẽ sửa nó giả
sử cái đoạn kiểm tra không tồn tại này
có vấn đề cũng không sao cả
ở Ninh Bình vẫn sẽ sửa được nó ở ngay
Mình thấy cái đây nó sẽ hợp lý hơn việc
là
kiểm tra tại này
Vì mình thấy trên cái sách flow này có
nhiều bạn trả lời rất hay anh Cử mình
học hỏi cố từ người khác đấy
là đầy chỗ một chàng trai chàng lập
trình các bạn học công nghệ thông tin
này ra các bạn biết xanh đấy rồi à
cho các bạn học thực sự là mình học
khi
mình học các thù với họ chủ yếu toàn là
không không có trên một cái trang khóa
học nào cả nên em thực sự các bạn hỏi
mình khóa nào ổn anh không gặp chắc đi
trả lời nha
Đang ngồi chơi à các bạn hỏi người khác
thôi
và Không không bài toán ở đây đó là kiểu
chuyến Chắc là ổn với mình sẽ ổn với bạn
mà ngoan các bạn hãy phải tự cảm thấy
nếu mà nó miễn phí cho trời là miễn phí
một vài buổi giờ các bạn học thử nó tốt
Còn không thì đúng kiểu các bạn cũng 50
50 đó
không gì Chắc chắn là các bạn bỏ tiền ra
các bạn sẽ học ổn cả bởi bởi vì các bạn
cũng biết đâu có rất nhiều người mất
tiền oan vụ đấy
bây giờ gần bám được rồi đúng không ạ
Giờ đang có tên 60 người
Xin chào sau buổi hôm trước thì lượng
người bắt đầu giảm hẳn cảm thấy ở ban
đầu nó chuyên sâu quá ơi à
kỹ thuật toán thì các bạn không cần phải
chuyện nó đã bị khóa EXO đến bây giờ
mình cũng mình cũng vận dụng thật toàn
đi lắm mà đi ray và tìm thì cái rất là
tốt để mà các bạn muốn cậu bởi vì một
vài công ty Đúng là tuyển
nhưng mà thực ra là facile à cái đã
không lên đòi họ gì nhiều và cà phê xơ
cả xơ cho ta chỉ cần biết toàn bộ cơ bản
cũng như là có cái gọi là có khó tinh
thần như thế họ sẽ đánh giá cao về mặt
tinh thần hơn chứ kinh nghiệm hay Kiến
thức là mấy cái đấy có thể bổ sung sau
à à
nhà mình có biết dùng pin đâu mà hướng
dẫn
Ok nói chung bây giờ bắt đầu buổi học là
không ạ Mình sẽ chữa bài Bố hôm trước
nhé
Khi
bữa hôm trước thì thử k là
Ừ cái câu 3 sao ấy thường ra có nhiều
bạn Mình thấy bạn gần cuối bạn là nó trả
lời tương đối ổn rồi nhưng mình không
chắc là mình không nên chữa hẳn có 3 sao
này mà mà
à mà để cho buổi sau với chi cơ mình sẽ
chữa và các bạn sẽ thấy khi mà dụng chỉ
cơ vào thì câu 1 sao ạ Nói cho mấy câu
này và sự ra dễ hơn dễ dễ hơn nhiều
anh
à mấy câu này được ra ở mới khấu trước
thì nó lại có trong buổi ông như trước
mình chữa rồi nhỉ
ừ ừ
cho mấy con này mình nhớ hôm nào nó hôm
trước mình là mình đã chữa mấy cái này
rồi Thế thôi chắc là mình nhảy sang Hàn
thoáng trình nhé đầu
tiên thì cái phong trần đấy
fashion từ ra có hai loại
Nó là loại Bean
song sinh và một loại là loại à
user-defined phang chuẩn
thi
cái cái này hiện đầy đủ Story như này
phải Win nhé Thì nếu mà dịch nôm na ra
là sẽ là kiểu nó được dựng sẵn nó có sẵn
ở trên trong trong cái hệ cơ sở dữ liệu
này và vào cái này nếu mà dịch thu ra ấy
thì nó sẽ là người dùng nữa người dùng
định nghĩa
store đã được lưu đã được chị đã được
lưu lại Bởi người dùng định nghĩa ra Tức
là sao xa sử ở đây các bạn sẽ lại bộ hôm
trước là sự sẽ xa phóng sinh viên ở hạn
ông ạ
ai như mình không trưởng hôm trước mình
dốt thế thôi rồi xin với một điện
nó không có bạn nào chẳng hạn nó ngon Kể
cả không có bạn nào như này thì ra mình
vẫn có thể đếm được số bạn ạ ạ
ừ ừ
Ừ thì nó sẽ ra là không chẳng hạn đúng
không Không ngày thức à các bạn học qua
về cái Hà này các bạn biết rồi nói
chuyện giờ đến không có bạn nào trả lời
không ngờ bản chất ở đây nó là cái này
là belfort này đi em khoai Trần tất cả
các bạn thấy dùng hàng có sẵn của thằng
Amway nó có những cái hàm này hoa nó còn
những cái hạn gì nữa Thế Hệ hàm lấy thời
gian hiện tại này Xóa hàm săn hàm đến
gần nó ngon
thì nó lên billboards còn hôm nay mình
sẽ học nó sẽ là học là mình sẽ định
nghĩa làm cái phòng trừ mới thứ là cái
thứ hai chung là cực lớn nhất nữa hả
Mình sẽ có luôn điệp khúc và crash
khoáng chất như thế này
nhà đầu tiên thì mình cách tạo bảng chưa
mình sẽ tạo lại các bạn phê bổ sinh viên
để bạn sẽ hình dung đã
sửa đây mình sẽ có mã in DAMtv tự động
toàn không ạ
xong rồi Anh tên
và trà trả
sau đó thì mình sẽ có
à à
Ờ Ờ
mình sẽ có giới tính là kiểu để kiện ít
đi và mình sẽ có như mình đã nói mình
không nên lưu tuổi của người dùng bởi vì
cái đấy thì tình toàn được và cứ xanh
Nam thì dùng để thay đổi tuổi không ạ
Mình sẽ lưu lại là ngày sinh năm sinh
Rồi ạ Hoàng ngày sinh gì đó đóng ngoặc
ngày sinh điện sẽ để cậu biết như thế
này đó là tự nhiên mình sẽ có khóa chính
cho chúng đầy đủ
là sự nhà chắc lại ạ
Ừ Ok bây giờ xử mình sẽ đi sát vào bạn
sinh viên
tên giới tính ngày sinh
ở đây sẽ là
người tính là một nước ngoài
1970 11 hạ
là đây thật ra sự đây Anh Tuấn ra cho
không Này 2.000 chỗ ạ Ngày đúng không
cho sửa mình có hai bạn
ở trận
sau đó snack sao form sinh viên ạ ạ
ở top miền Nam đây
[Vỗ tay]
Ừ
thì ở đây các bạn sẽ xảy ra nó sẽ ra
thông tin tưởng nhớ này viết ra hiển thị
thông tin như thế này cho người dùng rất
là khó chịu Tại sao ạ Bởi vì các bạn
thấy Hiển thị một cái không với người
dùng bình thường dùng bình thường sẽ
trải nghiệm một Với 0 điểm gì tiếp theo
là hiển thị ra kiểu ngày sinh như này
Thực ra thì người dùng đôi khi không có
tâm ngày sinh này ra quan tâm đến tuổi
hoài cùng nó năm sinh của người ta thôi
Thì bây giờ mình sẽ hiển thị như thế nào
thì nó sẽ có nhiều cách ở đây mình sẽ
thử nhé
đã sửa đây mình sẽ điền lại là sẽ lacta
này giới tính ngày sinh này Đây đây nó
sẽ Nham bằng sẽ lexar của mình thôi đúng
không Nhưng bây giờ mình bắt đầu thay
thế dần là không sẽ là gì một sẽ là gì
để ngoan
thì kiểu như thế là sử ra sự là mình sẽ
có thể dùng chú
ý tem ở đây cũng được
cây quen mình thức thường hay dùng cây
quen với trong này cây số em nó chuẩn
hơn
Tức là sao mà mình kiểm tra nếu mà giới
tính bằng một này đúng ngoan thì Zen này
sẽ in là Nam em ạ eo mình sĩ nữ được ạ
nữ này
rồi em này đây này chạy thử nè
đó các bạn sẽ thấy là một cái không nắng
đội nó thành nam với nữ đồng loạt và nó
không có tên cụ ở đây mình có thể cho nó
vào trong về ngót tròn như hai sao mình
sẽ app is ở đây tên cột lại tên giới
tính nào ạ ạ
Ừ nó như thế này thì các bạn sẽ thấy ra
à ok Cái này nó là bản chất là gì nó nói
ít theo ngay lúc mà mình in ra vì sẽ in
từng cái hang này ra một và trong lúc mà
mình in ra đúng ạ Mình sẽ lấy được cái
cục thời tình cũ để mà mình
mình kiểm tra xem nó phù hợp với cái
điều câu điều kiện của mình không là câu
tiếp theo đây động hoặc kiểm tra nếu
dịch tính bằng 1 thì mình sẽ hiển thị
cho chị nam giới tính là còn ngược lại
đó mà ngược lại thì mình sẽ dị giới tính
nữ đúng thì thì đây mình sẽ
chị thay cái này bằng phẳng chỉnh thì nó
sẽ như thế nào ạ Mình sẽ viết phóng
trình này
mình bản chất là mình đầu tiên mình vẫn
sẽ phải đặt tên nó phân trần đời đã mình
sẽ đặt tên Phong Trần là ứng dụng loại Ừ
nếu mà để tiếng Anh thôi để nặn hết bằng
tiếng Việt Anh ấy là tên giới tính ạ
thì để bên cạnh tiếng Việt đi ạ mình để
thì mày đi họa nếu viết tắt thường là
viết tắt họ sẽ là như thế này
van xin chứng nhận
Thôi mình cứ để đầy đủ đi cho con đợi
phải tắt thì cả hai nó sẽ phải truyền
một cái gì đó vào trong cái này trong
trường hợp này mình truyền cái giới tính
và đúng không ạ và giới tính này nó số
mình sẽ để chuyển giới tính
giới tính vào à
Ê
thằng Phát triển nó sẽ có thêm những
kiểu quy tắc nó đầu tiên là các bạn có
thể truyền tham số vào thì phải khai báo
kiểu như thế này
tiếp theo là sau đó thì mình sẽ phải trả
trả về trả về một cái phải luôn khai báo
sẽ trả lời cái gì thì trả về ở đây chẳng
phải chữ này mình sẽ Return chả nọ
Return Duy Tân có chữ f nhá vào chữ s là
cái thứ mình sẽ về này Peter nó là
Nevada đúng không ạ Đừng bỏ ra 50 này đó
sau đó thì các bạn sẽ luôn của anh và em
cho điệp khúc Như ngay sau đó các bạn sẽ
copy rồi đoạn này anh
ở đây mình sẽ ghi kiểu ngày cho gọn dễ
hình dung mà Wen giới tính bằng một gen
Return Nam em ạ
sau đó thì em ở đây này
I
Return nữ trả lại ạ
xe tải
Anh vừa chạy thử
xin lỗi tại bit nhớ ảnh ngựa phía sau
này thì phải
có cây cây từ những xem lại nhé
a Nhớ Mỹ Duy Tân ở đây theo chuẩn đi tơ
nữa đây là như này đi
chả được đấy à
khi con luôn giới tính nóng Ôi cái này a
còng mình chuyển giới tính vào không
không còn là có luôn nữa
đó rồi đúng không ạ ạ
Anh ở trong trường hợp này thì ở trong
SQL thì nó lại ngược lại mà luôn là tên
chứa tên dữ liệu trước sau đó thì mới
tên kiểu dữ liệu sau
luôn có Return là đây nhá mình phải trả
về một cái gì đó mà đúng không ạ
case when i kiện ngay đấy
Ừ thì bây giờ để mà mình gọi được cái
hàng này Hà Phong trên máy tính ở trong
này thì mình sẽ chỉ thay thế đoạn này là
con Trường tên giới tính sau đó chuyên
cột tới tính vào là xong để mình chẳng
hợp này
thì nó sẽ bị lỗi nó sẽ bảo lỗi này là
cái xong trên này nó không phải là Build
phong trần các bạn không gọi được dạng
như kiểu xoăn cao được như thế này à
Ừ đấy thì các bạn muốn gọi thì có bị
nghĩa
you ready for truyền đấy thì các bạn
phải thêm dbo xong rồi chấm như thế này
thì hiểu Nó là cái Hà mà các bạn vừa
khai báo thì cụ giờ đi file khoanh chân
Họ chạy thử này có thể kết quả nó vẫn sẽ
như nhau thôi như cách viết như thế này
nữa là các bạn sẽ tống hết cái xử lý nó
sẽ làm cải hàm riêng để máy hiển thị con
còn C của mình thì chị em đã gọi cái Hàn
đấy là được đâu mà
tiếp theo cũng tương tự Thế thì các bạn
sẽ thấy vừa rồi biết qua được cách gọi
của một cái phong trần nó ngoác đó sẽ dư
sử dụng pvo cho chấm thôi mà tên của hàm
sôi cái Hà mày bạn chất nó sẽ truyền vào
rất nhiều cái thậm chí ở bên Nếu mình
muốn dậy hồi của các bạn nhất để thì
mình sẽ classf Asen là ví dụ ra hàm + đi
Các bạn thấy muốn của cái hàng này rồi
ra sự ở mình chuyển A vào kiểu y này
chuyển bê và kiểu này mình sẽ cộng hai
số với nhau thì mình xin chào để cái
nóng à Xong rồi á sẵn này cái ghi nè e
này cho bạn chất là mình sẽ Return à Còn
a + a + b + thì đây mình muộn mình tạo
cái hàng này ra và mình muốn gọi thì cái
Hàn này mình từng tạo vợ
ơi
mình tạm dốc ở đây nhá lốp bóng chuyền
này cộng này à
chỉ
có mình tạo lại hàng này nha đó ông ạ
ở đây mình muốn gọi hàng này chỉ có bạn
lại thấy là slex Evo chấm + số chuyển
hai số vào trà sữa các bạn không biết số
1 cộng với số 2 + số 3 bao nhiêu ạ Các
bạn gõ gõ như này sẽ trở về cứ gọi là
mùng 4
thì các bạn sẽ thấy bài toán ở đây nó sẽ
là cần nhớ Thứ nhất là tên của hàm mình
có thể truyền vào hoặc không truyền Tùy
các bạn Các bạn thích thì trả về hẳn một
cái gì đó luôn là sự à
có một cái hàm không cần truyền về tham
số gì cả đúng không Đây
hàm trả về số
2.000 21 Chọn nó chả còn truyền đi cả và
nó trả về 20 21 kéo này cũng được
cũng được đúng à chẳng đi sai được đấy
đi hàn mày nó sẽ chỉ đơn giản là trả lời
2021 nhà ấy một trong những cái giờ đơn
giản của các phóng sinh đúng không Đó là
các bạn sẽ thấy là nó có thể truyền tham
số nào hoa không cần chuyện cũng được
sau đó nhỉ các bạn sẽ thêm vì trơn thêm
chữ s nhé nhớ phải thêm chữ s và khai
báo Kiểu của nó sẽ trả về sau đó thì
mình sẽ đã bị zener Điệp một mà mình sẽ
thêm chữ rito mà sự nó sẽ xào với cái gì
đây là những cái rễ
bờ tiết heo xanh cái nâng cao Thêm một
tí
ừ ừ
ờ ờ Giả sử bây giờ đến ngày sinh đều
ngoan thì các bạn để lấy ngày sinh gì
đâu nha các bạn sẽ lấy
lấy ra tuổi không ạ sử Thế các bạn muốn
in ra tuổi là sử mình muốn có một cái
hàm Tưởng như hai là ngày sinh này
đi ô phong trần là
phong trần là ah
lấy tuổi em ạ
đây đó ông ạ em tuổi nghe đi
Ừ mình tại một cái khoảng trở lại đúng ạ
Mình sẽ crash on trên này
mình truyền ngày sinh vào có hoa là kiểu
bếp mình sẽ Return về
with ơn về kiểu tin rằng ạ sử các bạn
muốn giấu chị 5 tuổi nó chuẩn chứ không
phải phải phải vậy đó ông ạ thì ghi này
em này mà trận mình sẽ ghi tên rồi còn
cái gì đó khi ở đây Nếu các bạn muốn anh
kiểu đơn giản thì mình sẽ lấy là nền năm
của hiện tại - năm của cái thằng này là
được đúng không ạ
đến đi thì phải nhớ đấy
kia này sẽ chuyện này sinh này
và gas bếp ê
bí
đỏ này
nhiêu được nhiều được
để mình thử thử trước nhé Mà thôi mình
áp dụng luôn ở trên này được mà
chạy này đó ổn rồi Nó không ạ
Đây vẫn chỉ là mấy gái nó vẫn cơ bản
thôi
có bạn theo kiểu lại các bạn hoàn toàn
là truyền mà một thứ gì đó rồi tính toán
gì đó để nó sẽ để lại kết quả đúng không
ạ
Thế còn cái nào có thể phức tạp hơn thì
cái phong trần này ra một trong những
cái khó của nói đây mình sẽ cho bạn xem
cái ví dụ ở đây mình có ai cập
100 những cái khó của nó có thể là nó
hoàn toàn thể Return Thay bồ toàn hệ
anh chả phải cảm cái bảng cho các bạn
đây ra xử ra sự nhé
là sử là các bạn Nhớ buổi hôm trước mình
học là mình có biết voz em sinh viên
ngoan
Các bạn nhớ vụ này không ạ ủ sẽ lưu
Xem sinh viên ngoãn
sau đó thì các bạn sẽ truyền mã vào kiểu
in này
lại xong rồi Beginning and không ạ Rồi
Starex sao form sinh viên
Where mã bằng có mã đối ngoại như này
hôm trước còn tạo này rồi đúng không
Mình sẽ rốt vào đi nhé
à à
I
can not you
It's table và Plus One Thing I
à à
ừ ừ
anh
à hình như có phong trên này rồi ạ
thông báo
à À hiểu mình tạo phong trên đây rồi
Không sao đây khi bây giờ mình sẽ đây do
và đôi khi ở để tránh nhầm mình thường
hay có viết tắt của cái á cái tắt của
cái này trước để cho mình nhớ nó là cái
gì không bị chụp nó không được cái chung
kể cả tăng Trần và code rồi không được
phép trùng tên nhau
có đồng bọn
mình lần trước mình chạy ở cạnh ngay là
sự thật và mã bằng một cho bạn đó ngoãn
chạy như này kia sẽ là mấy ra toàn bộ
sinh viên toàn bộ sinh viên có mã bằng 1
đóng ngoặc ra chỉ có một bạn thôi nhớ
cách này thử không ai áp dụng cách này
cho bố sẽ đưa cả mà chuẩn là bây giờ cái
gì mà chả bị dữ liệu gì đó thì mình sẽ
đẩy sao người phongtrần để làm điều đấy
sẽ clip phương trình là phần sinh này
xem sinh viên đúng không ạ ở
đó Sao Bây giờ mình chuyển mã vào như
thế này get ơn về thuê bộ và cái này cái
này hồi nãy mình mò mãi mới ra được đó
là riêng cái trường hợp Twitter mà trả
về phần của cái bảng như này thì các bạn
sẽ không được dùng Aspirin và em không
dùng được
cái này bắt buộc phải dùng cái mà không
ghi tên về thay đổi các bạn báo vội dùng
cái này điều hòa và phải gọi còn cái này
thì các bạn chỉ có Return thẳng luôn như
thế này nó Pit ơn selects
sao form sinh viên đúng không que
a mã vàng mã
ở nhà thôi
em có và bây giờ cách thì gọi đến hàng
này thì các bạn lại select sao for thằng
này
Anh
đang nhìn anh
chờ
đợi bình tĩnh snack này thôi thì phải
có rule name
sao phom đúng rồi ạ nhưng phải review
nói vậy ạ
anh
không không phải video Nhớ à Đúng rồi
ngồi chuyển mã quên 1A
thì
các bạn sẽ thấy là riêng riêng cái vụ
Thay bồ này nó sẽ biến thành như một cái
bạn mới rồi các bạn nó ngoan nó giống
Thằng Biêu ý nhưng thằng này nó khác với
thằng vi của mạch điện và có thể truyền
tham số còn hàng hàng ngày chị đấy đúng
rồi nó trở khát Hồng Vi Hổ điểm trong
trường hợp này nó chuyển đến 5 số thầm
phòng view thì các bạn nhớ là mình sẽ
phải vì tham số ngoài giống như kiểu
mình sẽ là select sao for view là nó
đúng không mưu sinh viên ạ ạ Mình nhớ
hồi đấy đây này xong quen mã bằng mã như
thế này đúng không ngủ đấy mình làm view
mình sẽ về truyền tham số ở ngoài như
này con lần này mình chuyển hẳn như thế
này và nó giống họng view là nơi kiểu nó
vẫn là bảo mật Đúng không thực sự mới
dùng sẽ không biết được là cái bảng
chuẩn của mình nó sẽ
tên là gì và có những cái cột vì sự mình
lên mình vì vậy tất cả cột mình chỉ thấy
một vài câu thôi đúng không ạ
Tại đây đây đây sẽ là đầy đủ của cây từ
trả về dữ liệu theo kiểu là các bạn thấy
vừa rồi mình trả lời cả chữ này chả phải
có số này trở về cảm cái bà ta sẽ như
thế nào
chả về một thấy bổ tự định nghĩa a đây
thì cái bài toán ở đây đó là sẽ cái câu
select này nó sẽ khác với code yêu ở
điểm mà nó sẽ không chạy được Insert
update Delete
cái mình mình từ hỏi các bạn và không
biết các bạn còn nhớ không Cái khái niệm
DL đó là data free fire
language gì đó đúng không khi các DL tất
cả nó sẽ bao gồm press
enter mà không tạo được bà không không ở
bảng mà không sửa bạn ạ Không phải mỗi
bảng đâu nó sẽ ra bao gồm cả tạo là bố
sẽ điều hay tạo
tạm phong trần gì rõ Vân Vân Vân Thi
Thăng thằng quá trình này nó không chạy
được BL tiếp theo là dml tất cả data
manipulation
là chi phối cái cái trên là định nghĩa
đúng không mà đi
thì không nhớ chính xác cụm từ lắm
mày nhiều đại khái Thế các bạn xấu hổ sẽ
biết mà Thì thì nó là sẽ là những câu
lệnh Insert update Delete nghĩa là thay
đổi thay đổi cái dữ liệu
thì thằng Phát triển nó cũng sẽ không
chạy được nốt cả cái này nữa không Sao
anh vẫn đi lấy được Nghĩa Đồng Nghĩa
được à trong câu phong trần các bạn chỉ
có khai báo biến và các bạn
a black trả về một cái gì đó trả về một
giá trị trả phải biến hay dùng iPad Air
vẫn thử thứ chứ không tạo ra được một
cái bảng ở trong nó giống thằng ngu đã
từng là đồ ngoại thành phố sẽ lưu các
bạn nhiều âm nó tạm được cả bà mày tạo
được bạn tạm thời này Đấy Nghĩa thành
phố C bị u đi Ủa nó làm được hết cả DL
đó là đêm em còn thăm thằng thằng mai
này chúng nó sẽ chỉ là được lại bql thôi
Nó data quay language để ngoan thế ngôn
ngữ ngôn ngữ truy vấn tất cả nó là mỗi
cái nó chạy được đĩa xôi lách đường này
đấy
[âm nhạc]
đợi mình đi con chó nó người quá đấy đi
à
anh alo
em Tự nhiên hôm nay không hiểu sao cậu
Nhà cửa thì phải dọn phòng con chó thì
tranh thủ phá
ok Nói chung là về phân Trần ghi là đối
với mình nghĩ nó cũng sẽ không hoàn dài
lắm nhưng mình nói nó không hẳn khó loa
Các bạn thấy nó vẫn đơn giản nhưng mà
nãy giờ thì ra là nó cũng chưa hẳn mức
độ khó Còn nếu các bạn khó hơn giống như
mình thấy mình có làm ở đây đó là các
bạn hoàn toàn bệnh trong anh nhiều bảng
với nhau để mà ra được hoặc cao thậm chí
dùng cái phong trần này trong Word cũng
được
trang wed được ví dụ là kiểu
anh ở đây là mình sẽ có hàm
kiểu như này Điện
krise Phương Trinh
fashion kiệm kiểm tra tuổi I
ở trên 18 lần ạ
là sửa ngày để ngoan thì mình cũng sẽ
truyền và là ngày sinh đi
đết này chính sẽ Return ở đây là này
mình ghi tên bit thì trở về đúng hoặc
sai rồi chẳng hạn đúng không ạ sau đó
thì ở đây mình sẽ có ai bị ghi này em
này lần này mình sẽ copy cũng giống cái
ở trên này đó là mình lấy tuổi nhưng lần
này mình sẽ So sánh nó với Twitter này
nhưng lần này mình sẵn sàng nói với 18
tuổi em ạ
thì bản chất cái này nó sẽ trả về là nếu
mà Ngày sinh hợp lệ chị sẽ là sẽ thỏa
mãn cái 18 tuổi này họ sẽ cậu chạy được
mà mình chạy thử các bạn
Khi
so sánh này Tại sao không được
không the
Ừ cái này rồi mày nghỉ Đợi mình tí đâu
Tí
à à
À mà thôi Mình chưa tròn ấy 18 lớn không
anh không đúng nhỉ à
Ừ hình như ở trong này nó không có so
sánh chợ này Nếu thế thì không sao Mình
mình cứ lấy ra tuổi Sau đó thì mình à
có ai lấy ra tuổi thì 18 cùng so sánh nó
với không cái đoạn quen cũng được tình
nhiều cách mà nó ngon
thì mình tạm bỏ lại đi tạm không cần mày
nữa
chắc là nó không cho dù copy ở trong
file thì mình sẽ cứ lấy tuổi nhưng
thường nhé
Tôi chưa lấy tuổi đúng không Mình sẽ
mình sẽ lại mình lấy tất cả sinh viên đủ
tuổi hạ sinh viên như này Where
divio.com trần đấy tuổi này truyền cột
ngày sinh vào này không còn -18 xong rồi
nó không ở đây là điều gì đúng không ạ
chạy này các bạn thấy em nói vẫn sẽ ra
tuổi đúng không ạ anh
ở đây ở đây Chắc chắn là những bạn này
thì nó trên 18 tuổi rồi sợ sự là mình sẽ
lấy thật sự là lấy 250 ạ
ở đây không có bạn nào chưa 25 cả đổi 24
nhãn thì sẽ có 1 rau xanh đấy tuổi vừa
nãy rõ phản có bạn trên
ở trên mà ở
anh em trả lại nhé các bạn hãy trên lại
24 tuổi thôi cái kiểu như thế thì các
bạn sẽ thấy là
cái đêm u này cái hàm quanh trường này
có thể dùng được cả trong Word Và thậm
chí nó có thể cho được Mình soi được hạn
của bạn thấy bồ khác Nếu như trong
trường hợp ở đây nhá Mình có thể là sếp
select như thế này đúng không ạ xong rồi
voi với 9 lại bạn sinh viên à ạ kiểu như
ai on cái cục gì đó là sinh viên chấm mã
bằng để Adidas đi
Asiad đây là
Facebook một tí nữa này
thêm một chấm mã ngay vẫn chạy được
ở đó bạn sẽ thấy da tăng trưởng bây giờ
nó sẽ tính bằng một cái bảng và hoàn
toàn thể do được cả 4 cái bảng khác kiểu
như này
và phong trần Thậm chí còn dùng được
trong cả que vân vân
ừ ừ
mở
mã khóa trên Apple
10 Thực ra là mã hóa các bạn sẽ dùng
ngôn ngữ lập trình chứ không không lại
dùng FBI để mà là mã hóa được
à à
sự tăng trưởng có tham số rồi quay
Insert
Delete qua thăm số
em
không ở trong phong thủy mình nhớ nó
không chạy được câu lệnh Insert Delete
Thôi để mình thử nhé
Thử Thử thì biết thôi đó ngon sự mình sẽ
classf span xin
xóa sinh viên em ạ
thì chuyện ở đây là mã này kiểu in này à
Return về một cái gì đó kiểu đi
Aspirin này
elite four
sinh viên Where mã bằng mã
pro select How tall is
where mã mã kiểu ngay chạy thử nhé ah
Peter này mình ghi tên hàng thì thấy bồ
đi khác không
Mình Return này một đi ra sắt đúng không
ạ
Ở
đây các bạn sẽ thấy nó lỗi mà nó khai
báo là không không sử dụng Delete ở
trong toàn trường được mà cái Insert
cũng sẽ thế thôi chả Bạn áp dụng ở trong
nhà máy quét mã QR mình chưa thử nhé
nhưng mà chuẩn về về lý thuyết mình nhớ
chắc thì nó là trong quá trình sẽ không
dùng được dml 2 dl
a fashion hyperview dùng được nhiều hơn
Không cái này là tùy tùy công ty các bạn
thực ra là có nhiều nhiều công ty mình
từng mình từng tiếp xúc thì người ta lại
không dùng một tí
view Để phong trần hypo CPU hay là thích
cơ mà nó sẽ tập trung làm hết toàn bộ ở
bên bác em ngôn ngữ lập trình nào xử lý
nhưng mà
chị nhiều là những đấy những công ty bé
và mình thường đặt mình không chưa gặp
không tin lớn sẽ ăn trộm như em như mình
đã nói được ra cái này liên quan vấn đề
về bảo mật nữa Thực sự không phải ai
cũng được phép chọc thẳng vào DB để nó
xem toàn bộ trong bảng để có những cái
gì kể cả cho dù cột nó được mã hóa nữa
Nhưng có rất nhiều cột nó vẫn kiểu nghị
cả mấy kiểu dạng như này đưa các bạn sẽ
xa foam bảo khách hàng không ạ sau đó
thì các bạn thấy đấy à khách hàng này
thanh toán rất nhiều hóa đơn rồi xong
rồi Các bạn thấy được email nữa là số
điện thoại người ra các bạn lưu lại toàn
bộ những thông tin khách hàng Vì sao đói
Vì sao các bạn nghỉ việc các bạn có thể
dùng thông tin khách hàng đấy để các bạn
span telesale quảng cáo gì gì đó thì lôi
kéo khách hàng đối với công ty mới của
bạn sẽ hạ toàn bộ những thông tin về số
điện thoại hay là email địa chỉ vẫn cả
tên của khách hàng nếu như không có thể
lưu kẹt ở trên đấy được nhưng mà những
cái thông tin đấy hoàn toàn nó không mã
hóa chẳng ai mã hóa và mã hóa ấy chẳng
giải quyết vấn đề gì ạ thì nên là
ở những cái đấy chỉ đơn giản là không
nên cho lập trình viên trực tiếp biết
được điều đấy thôi đúng không thì các
bạn sẽ phải làm việc qua view để mở hoặc
là Oppo để mà thao tác với cái bạn đấy
chứ không được phép chọc thẳng và xếp
sao phòng cái bạn đời như thế
à à
Ừ đúng rồi hệ quản trị cơ sở dữ liệu
khác nhau để có thể nó sẽ khác nhau rồi
cái phương trình này nhưng mà thấy thì
nó không đúng nó không đúng về cái ý
nghĩa của nó nữa vì nếu thế thì nó không
khác gì vô Siri là ngọn thế này mình mới
dậy Cái bạn ấy là mình có thể dạy các
bạn hoàn toàn theo máy của em những thứ
em mai que là không đúng lắm về KS về
chuẩn seoweb và thằng mai có số pasquale
mới ra chuẩn nhất thế Mình mới dậy các
bạn ở trên Microsoft Word nhưng mà về
sau thì nếu mà sang bên web thì mình lại
phải dậy lại các bạn gửi mai qua em
nhưng mà
ở đó nó thay đổi tí thôi nhưng mà đương
nhiên là em quay chuẩn nhất thì phù hợp
và dạy ở trên cái nền tảng máy Microsoft
Word này
à à
ừ ừ
từ hôm nay mình mới đổi cái logo này
sang thai logo như thế này Đấy mình mới
xem lại các video của mình hội trước
mình đừng quay ấy thì mình hồi trước
mình dùng logo này nhưng mà gần đây là
mình mới cài lại máy nó bị xóa mất
Hôm nay chắc các bạn tình ý các bạn nhìn
thấy cái logo tim ở đây không ạ
cái logo này thì đã có bạn Chính thức ra
chính bạn trong nhóm mình từng chia sẻ
cái ảnh logo đấy Đấy mình mới tải về cơ
mà cái ảnh đấy
À thế à Các bạn của với ảnh như thế này
đúng không ạ sau đó thì các bạn dùng cài
thêm một cái ra Classic
Classic Shell
Ừ cái này trên win mới có thôi các bạn
cài thêm cái này cho các bạn chọn vào
các bạn nhớ chọn cái này
em
chọn cái custome ở chọn là cái ảnh như
các bạn nên nhớ nhé cài cái này nó sẽ
mặc định là đổi các bạn về cái định dạng
kiểu dạng là classic mà tức là đơn giản
mà tất cả cái cái start menu menu này
của các bạn nó sẽ thay đổi như các bạn
muốn taman menu các bạn vẫn giữ nguyên
đấy thì các bạn sẽ phải ở bên bên cái
basic này các bạn đổi hết toàn bộ những
cái lép Rick mấy cái đây này
Đấy thành nhà Windows chapman menu chứ
không phải đổi hình classic menu
stallman u không đổi hết
Ừ đúng rồi bà đôi khi nó sẽ thay luôn cả
trong này mình thấy khó chịu này chắc
mình sẽ ẩn nó luôn đi
Ừ cái thử ta cái này xong nó có cái ức
chế riêng sẽ tự nhiên đổi của mình nhiều
cái cục nghe là mình phải ẩn hết đó đi
Ừ Nó kiểu nó nghĩa là sẽ tốt Nhưng thì
ra là mình không cần những cái điều đấy
thì mình chỉ cần đội mỗi ngày men cái
biểu tượng đây thôi mà
đi xe Suka đủ kiến thức của hôm nay ở
các bạn thấy kiến thức hôm nay nó rất
ngắn nó ngoác và cũng cơ bản không khó
lắm hôm trước mình có nói mà có khó lắm
đâu nhưng các bạn cũng sẽ phải đọc qua
cái ở dưới này nhá tổng hợp sự khác biệt
giữa
đấy Mình có nói đúng không cục sữa đi
phương trình với
sau rồi bu để các bạn hiểu về sau hỏi
mượn đáp thì sẽ sở được đúng không ạ
à à
em
sợ bài tập bài tập mua mạnh không thể
dài được đâu quá đúng ai
à à
à à anh
không Mình có biết bị thon đâu thì thon
là ngôn ngữ của người yêu cũ mình sẽ
ghét cái ngôn ngữ dậy
bây giờ thừa vẫn còn thời gian chắc là
mình sẽ tranh thủ ngồi chia sẻ vừa nãy
mình có tổng hợp lại các video có thể
chia sẻ các bạn thôi Ngồi xem tạm video
thì hết rồi nhé tạm cái ghế
Ừ em cứ nghe người cũ Tôi mỉm cười nữa
nhé Quên nó đi khỏi nó quá khứ đi
ra tôi không coi nó quá khứ không quên
nói đi ừ
tôi có những cái cái này hay cực
không mình không thấy con nhỏ đó mình có
biết gửi cái đấy đâu mình không nắm rõ
lý thuyết thì dạy những cái khó như hết
à
anh kể cái này hay cực Cái này là có gì
ông từng hỏi tôi đó là Kiều
mấy ông Nếu đôi khi ông chẳng hiểu sao
thích chạy mấy cái kiểu dạng mà cuộc thi
kiểu dáng mà bài đăng nào nhiều luật
chia sẻ nhiều lời thích hơn thì sẽ được
điểm cao hơn Ngón Vân Vân để tạo hiệu
ứng hết cùng mấy ông không lại thấy mấy
thằng khác nó ngồi spa chia sẻ các thứ
nên này nhìn cái rõ ràng có một ông chưa
dài Do sản thế lại phải phải hỏi tu nào
để mà ngồi lọc có những cái điều đấy thì
tôi làm cái tool kiểu ngay
đây tôi đang hướng dẫn tải về thôi bỏ
qua đi
ở Đài nó xảy ra được cái trang web về
như thế nào
Hồi này vẫn còn giao diện rất là xấu
nhưng mà tôi vẫn ngon thế được không ạ
nhập ID họ mấy cái bài đăng này lại ID
Mày đang dẫn 2 căn 5 chia sẻ cho ngoan
suốt cả bài nữa bài này lên đến 400 rồi
chia sẻ kiểu kiểu như thế sự xem Thực sự
nó được bao nhiêu giờ sẻ nhé á
ở
bài này có đúng có 370 74 là chia sẻ
Ê máy bài bài lên mỗi 500 này cái kiểu
gì thế thế Hồi này mình là do diện vẫn
còn xấu thời tiếp theo là cái giao diện
cho mẹ ngon lành hơn không phải đánh đi
làm đấy ạ
à à
anh lại kể cái này thì nó nó là còn Lộc
cả bình luận chung mà lập chia sẻ chung
là lọc được Thích Vân Vân rất nhiều cái
cô đến mình làm cũng ngon phết
ạ Bây giờ Bây giờ thực ra vẫn còn dùng
được nếu mà ông ấy ngậm Lấy cho tao quen
thứ hai tay thì ra Facebook nó thay đổi
cách để lấy mình cái này rồi
phải phải sửa lại cái api một tí
Anh Lộc lọc nick dòng nick ảo này đúng
các bạn để ý kĩ nhé Mình có thêm một vài
cái giống như cặp
lập nick rồng nách nạm đây không ảnh đại
diện này nét không còn tồn tại đây
xe tải lọc nick ảo theo bài 5 nghĩa lượt
vượt tương tác của bé đang nó thấp vậy
lọc chưa phải là thành viên nhóm là sự
theo kiểu muốn kiểu dạng lại chị thành
viên nhóm này vừa tính không ạ ấy còn
tất cả những cái kiểu như thế này
phim Hai Số Phận lọc
Ừ cái này hồi này là cốt mình có còn
trong đều lắm Khổ đấy mình mới mấy cái
cẩu vừa tự học vừa ngồi làm thực ra là
vẫn còn điều trị mức tương đối này thôi
như thế này thử gặp mình tự hào hoa đấy
mình tự hào có rỡ và cái này không thể
đến lên hạng 7 phút như này được code
mình đã phải nhanh lắm
à à
cô bạn kia đã nói việc là có nên dùng
tăng trưởng để mà kiểu hiển thị ra số
giống kiểu mãi là ngon cẩu Ví dụ ở bệnh
bách khoa B k0001 đúng gọi thì cái đấy
và mình nên dùng ngôn ngữ lập trình làm
hơn là dùng word để làm cái vụ đấy à
à à
ở đây hôm trước là tôi có chia sẻ cho
nhóm Hà bên khóa
à hóa học ở web là Tải ảnh rồi còn bây
giờ sẽ tải video nó sẽ trông như thế nào
con gà nó tương đương cốt của nó chẳng
thay đổi thì mấy rồi
Thật sự đây tôi lấy cái ID của về
add ID và pass mà
khi xảy ra một cái ID epad đây đúng
không xong rồi lại giao diện trông rất
là xấu nhưng mà miễn là cô chạy được là
được không ạ
ừ ừ
à à
cha mẹ có những cái video rất thú vị mà
em để cái cốt để mà Tải toàn bộ video từ
từ 1 pass hoặc là thậm chí ép một trang
cá nhân về nhóm thì hồi đấy là tôi chưa
làm được
à à
khi sex
anh có thể sắp xếp lại những buổi dậy
vườn kiến thức môn nào ra muốn đó Ừ ra
là mua nào của mình cũng để để Đều ghi
rõ ở trên cái tiêu đề các bạn hãy xem
theo TD thôi
và mình có ghi rõ buổi mấy buổi mấy rồi
mà
à à
à Tôi đang hướng dẫn mấy ông hỏi làm hư
mà ông đâu mà tôi đang dẫn mày ông ạ Để
để làm mấy cái ra không thì khó cả cốt
tất cả mấy cái này gần đưa nó chưa để
mua cho lòng Cốt
cho ví dụ điển hình ở đây là cái này Tại
hôm trước nói rồi đấy đang ra sự Cái này
sáng Chúng tôi có một cái file với đấy
tự nhiên có một anh ở trong nhóm này là
chia sẻ một cái file tex có tận
65.000 dòng
Khi dòng lạnh mỗi rằng là một linh ảnh
lấy từ bên thăm bồ rồi cả anh ấy ngồi Do
anh ngồi cào hết toàn bộ ảnh ở trên mê
cái mấy cái pass mấy người thích về đó
lên được 65.000 cái đường lên ngay sau
đó thì hồi đấy à tôi bảo tôi là ăn
minjiang gái
nhập trang ám ảnh gái xinh đấy thì thì
tôi muốn tải hết là đống ảnh để về tôi
lọc thì tôi tự nhiên tôi phải cốt cái
đoạn này mà kiểu đọc được cái file
65.000 kia rồi tự động tải về chứ không
phải là kiểu tôi ngồi tại thủ công về
copy pate thủ công từng cái lính ảnh
không kho tôi không nộp thuế tự nhiên là
thằng IDM nó có hỗ trợ vụ đầy đấy in em
em có hỗ trợ vụ inbox được file vào
nhưng mà thằng in animal nó Nó kiểu nó
hỗ trợ mức tương đối thôi lần đấy lần
đấy filepost vào nó cũng chết luôn cởi
mở bây giờ tôi phải Cốt em lắm đấy à
a key Word để làm được cái tu nè
Ừ chắc chẳng cần key word gửi mấy ông
lên xem cố của tôi tôi xong rồi mày ông
cha được đúng cái Hà mà tôi dùng nó nó
là xong mà
à à
Em hãy tôi có file file này 65.000 dòng
đi thăm bồ
à à
ở đó sẽ nó sẽ tự động
thì nó sẽ tự động tải liên tục liên tục
về
Ừ cái này nó Tôi đang dùng ngôn ngữ p
thì các bạn dùng ngôn ngữ lập trình nào
được không khác gì nhau cả
em vừa rồi ở về qua mấy cái tool kiểu
thứ ra còn thêm một vài cái tool rất là
hai nữa hưởng như là còn nhiều bạn sẽ
cần phải vụ
cách lấy ID
à à
ê ê
xin hãy
cách
lấy ID từ ở một trang nào đó bất kỳ em ạ
là sự bấm vào đây để lấy được ID học
nhóm này
Anh bảo trong nhóm đấy thức anh đi nhóm
này vào trang cá nhân lấy được ID cá
nhân này
anh hoặc là vào pack thì lấy được ID của
page chọn hoặc cái đi bài đăng cái gì đó
quê tôi làm cái này bởi vì thứ ba này nó
các bạn 15 tung lên Facebook này các bạn
phải biết ID
Ừ đi mà lấy thông tin từ cái đi đấy
à à
Vì sao
anh không gọi hỏi bạn gái tôi người Nhật
nữa
à à
ở thời tiếp theo nữa là hôm trước có bạn
hỏi là làm tiện ích thì làm bằng ngôn
ngữ gì thì tiện ích Tôi đang làm sẽ là
làm bằng da Switch thứ mà các bạn có thể
sẽ được học trong cái khóa học web của
bạn ấy sẽ làm bằng đá Speed sau đó Chỉnh
ở cam Hiệp và cái HTML để làm đã được
cái chậu như này
ừ ừ
Hôm
nay tôi không dẫn tải về mà
em lại nói chung là có một cái tiện ích
nhóm lợi ích này là Hồi đấy tôi chặn
quảng cáo này chặn mấy cái nút các tiểu
tử này đó
ạ sau đó thì tôi mà lại sang thôi
a complete Suite làm từ đấy chuyển bắt
buộc phải làm bằng da Speed
Ê
bà hồi đấy là tôi làm ở bờ rìa tôi thử
nhiều quá nhưng ơi thằng Facebook ghét
tôi nó còn không hiển thị quảng cáo trên
trên trang của tôi nữa nên tôi phải làm
thay thế toàn bộ váy đăng hình quảng cáo
em chọn đến để mua Thôi anh sẽ hiển thị
ra tôi còn bấm được biết phải cảnh nhé
Mấy ông thấy tôi cậu thay thế luôn cả
bài đăng bài bằng ảnh gái xinh lại
thường về như thế
à tiện mà không ạ ạ
ở nhà đưa nhân tiện ích ngày của tôi
không dùng đỡ của việc tháng Facebook
lại thay đổi cơ chế rồi Cái này nhược
điểm khi các bạn theo thằng thứ ba như
thế là nó thay đổi cái gì mình lại phải
chạy theo rất là mệt
Ừ cái này còn version version 3 nữa Đó
là theo kiểu như này cô đấy tôi chặn
được cả
bình luận chứa tử khóa hoặc cả bài văn
chứa từ khóa nữa Rất là hay có rất nhiều
bạn cần lấy ví dụ điện hệ nhà tội ghét
một cái bình luận Họ ghét cái bài đăng
nào nhắc đến thất thất tình chia tay này
chính trị Vân Vân Vân này còn sự nhập và
thôi chẳng hạn Hồi đấy mình nhập giờ sự
chữa rồi chẳng hạn nó sẽ thấy ông nào
tên có chữ á ẩn hết ra xứ Huế
em thật sự thấy đó nhé
Ê mày có video này thì thỉnh thoảng mình
mới đang hơi mình đang đôi khi từ
bộ phim
cho mình đăng có thể ở trên kênh của
mình hoặc mình banh ở trong nhóm như tên
công ty
à à
có 2 Giả sử có một bài đăng mà không bị
ẩn nha nha Bình luận cũng có thể bị ẩn
là sự thế
em gà hồi đấy mình chưa làm được ẩn ẩn
bình luận bằng ẩn Xóa nút cái ảnh nó đi
Dù sao mình cũng sẽ nghiên cứu làm mấy
cái vụ đấy giọng nói chung à cái mục
tiêu của tiện ích bẫy của mình nó là
thưởng ẩn đi tất cả những thứ mình cảm
thấy khó chịu phiền phức Ở trên mạng xã
hội từ bình luận mà từ 75 này sẽ ẩn hết
đi
Nam nào giống như mình mình còn khó chịu
ở những cái bài mà họ chia sẻ cho bạn
hết
ừ ừ
khi mình đã ví dụ thế thôi không phải
các bạn làm thế sẽ phải làm về gái đâu
mà cái này chị em nói là cách để các bạn
có động lực làm cái gì đó thôi mình có
động lực kéo thích ngắm gái thích chia
sẻ cái đấy cho người khác thì mình sẽ áp
dụng rồi đấy
ở đây phó những cái mà trải qua đường
gái mấy ông nhé Ví dụ ở đây Tôi có một
loạt ạ một loạt các đường link này cơ
thể từng link này biến hình ID Facebook
cũng được
ừ ừ
Ừ hai cái này là
toàn bộ điều dùng tool hết đấy dùng tool
để mà lọc Mà này
Ừ
để xem nữa
anh
như kiểu như này
ở đây tôi sẽ lấy hết toàn bộ bình luận
từ cái bài đăng này lấy được email
số của tất cả các bạn các bạn đấy chồng
ạ
à à
ừ ừ
cô này mày Ông vừa thấy không nghĩa tôi
sẽ lấy tất cả bình luận có chứa Email
nhé Không phải lấy được email từ từ cậu
Cái này em các bạn sẽ biết về khái niệm
về núi Jack về sau mình sẽ dạy các bạn
với khách sẽ lọc hết toàn bộ thông tin
để lấy những cái thứ mình muốn trong một
cái cậu một cái văn bản nữa là dài
A77 có lập trình Lập trình là nó làm hết
cho các bạn tự động từ a đến z tất cả
những cái vụ đấy
Ồ không Tôi có nói ngày mai xóa đâu Tôi
bảo là khi nào tôi ngủ dậy tôi sẽ xóa
thôi nhưng nhiều lúc rồi tôi ngủ dậy
được lên thật
Xin chào bạn Bích Ngân lấy chị
chứ còn cái gì nữa nhỉ
Ê nhớ à
Cho con thêm cái cuối này quấy được sẽ
rất phức tạp nha Tôi không biết là có em
mấy ông chưa Cái này Hồi đấy tôi làm cái
làm cái này tôi để mà chia sẻ tài khoản
ừ ừ
30 cách là để mà lọc cũng cả thay thế
thông tin thể lọc thay thế dữ liệu đ
ờ ờ
cái cái cái cái song với mày hồi để làm
đấy nó là để mang mang thiên hướng là
kiểu chia sẻ chia sẻ quyền xem trang cá
nhân người khác do sự là như là ông
đã có trường hợp như này đi là sửa Ông
chia tay với người yêu rồi em ạ
Bây giờ ông muốn vào để xem lại nick bạn
đấy nhưng mà bị ông chia tay ông chặn
rồi Hoặc cáo ủy các bạn rồi mà bạn kia à
Không đăng chế độ công khai không không
xem được không tin vào đấy thì ông muốn
là ông muốn xem xem bạn bài đăng của bạn
kia với tư cách bạn bè thôi chẳnghạn
cũng được đúng không ạ
À thì ra thằng bạn thân của ông lại lại
xem được thông tin của người yêu cũ của
ông để hạn nó bị hai đứa kết bạn với
nhau đã lại thế
thì nghĩa là thằng bạn thân của ông có
thể đưa nick của nó cho ông để ông đăng
nhập vào ứng xem đúng không như thế thì
lại nhạy cảm quá nó ông vào không thể
làm được rất nhiều cái chứ không phải
mỗi không phải mỗi cậu hả chị xem thế
kia thôi thì sẽ nên là tôi Hồi đấy tôi
là mở trang web này thiệu cậu đặt Ông
muốn thể chia sẻ góc nhìn của mình cho
người khác dùng cái video review mình
từng học kỳ I
Anh không phải người ta không công khai
vẫn xem được mà đang nói là cái thằng
thứ ba ấy nó xem được bài làm gì Thì ông
có thể chia sẻ cái quyền ông đang xem
đấy cho thằng khác được đấy nó trường
hợp đấy chứ không phải là thằng kia đăng
bài chế độ mình tôi mà cái trang web này
vẫn xem được đó nhé Không phải như thế
đâu nhé Mà cái việc là ông xem được cái
gì đó ngọn ông nhờ ông nhớ bài video Mẹ
Thứ tôi dậy rồi đúng không chia sẻ góc
nhìn của mình một phần góc nhìn của mình
cho người khác được mà toàn bộ góc nhìn
mình cho khác cũng được đấy nhưng mà
không chưa sang tài khoản của ông cho
người ta đúng ạ Mẹ người ta không để
đăng nhập vào tài khoản không người ta
sẽ bấm vào đường link đấy mà xem được nó
sẽ lại khá em như thế này
Em ở chỗ nào đương nhiên là ông phải
đăng nhập nick Facebook của ông vào đây
rồi để mà tôi lấy cho tao kem của ông
Thực ra là nghe thế nó hơi nguy hiểm thì
cho nó sẽ ra tôi chẳng chẳng lưu lại à
chúng chẳng để làm gì mấy cái các bạn
đấy à
xe tải về xem thử lên nhà Đấy Tôi vừa
tới chọn một vài bạn đúng không ạ một
vài bạn ở trong danh sách bạn bè tôi rồi
Bây giờ tôi chỉ việc bấm vào xem bất kỳ
bạn ở đấy thì sẽ ra toàn bộ thông tin
như này cái này sẽ rất là phù hợp với
việc ở muốn làm sticker hai ông kiểu
dạng là đôi khi là ông ông kiểu là ông
muốn mai mối bạn của mình cho một ông
nào đó chẳng hạn một ai đó mà bạn không
ạ Cái ông có thể lên đây ông ông gửi
đường link này cho họ họ vào thể xem qua
được toàn bộ thực sự người kia đăng
những cái gì về từ các bạn bè xem được
đâu mà ngày hôm đấy tôi làm theo dõi
ngay
giao diện được mới học không được đẹp
lắm
Ừ cái này ở xem được ảnh này xem trọn
video người đang xanh 15 để đăng này Vân
Vân Vân này
hồi đấy Mình đăng nhập ở đây mình không
bị chơi for gì cả Không biết là bây giờ
thằng Facebook nó bảo mật như thế nào
nó đương nhiên là hội cốt đấy Bây giờ
Bây giờ toàn bộ code file Facebook của
mình phải hơn 2 năm rồi mình không cập
nhật nên có thể có vài dãy nó xong thấy
bộ đổi rồi nó khó không làm được nữa nhớ
đại khái của đấy tôi làm như thế này
à à
ai đấy Cái cái bài toán Vừa rồi tôi nói
qua các bạn thế để các bạn biết được à
Làm một cái phần mềm thì các bạn chỉ cần
nghĩ tưởng ra sôi các bạn tìm cách để mà
làm thôi Đúng bọn nó không hẳn gì khó
khăn cả
toàn bộ mấy cái này tôi thấy Cốt nó bể
tôi có lại vẫn được bởi vì nó rất là rẽ
và các bạn chỉ cần tìm hiểu thêm về
Facebook Lấy thông tin Facebook như nào
là làm được thôi và vừa rồi còn biết qua
thì lại một tí về cái bill đó không ạ
Xem xem lại chia sẻ quyền xem nữa ngoạn
Vì
con cần gì có thể chia sẻ được mấy ông ở
nhà
tôi nghĩa Tại hệ thế có một cái video
của tôi đang rất nhạy cảm nữa không biết
là chia sẻ mấy ông ở đây mấy ông có số
bóc phốt tôi không nghe là thôi I
à à
em
yêu tinh Security cái gì cả
em làm tool centos mà người khác không
thấy đi cái này thực à
Ừ thì có nhiều cách
anh có thể dùng như tim sakati kìa bản
chất cái utxico ở nó sẽ là
khi mà ông Tải video về chị thường là
ông sẽ còn gửi thêm cảm cái đoạn thẳng
Facebook thường ai làm cơ chế đấy Gửi
lên sắc thuộc cái việc và ông đã xem
video đấy thì thằng như tim protein nó
tắt
nó chặn cái việc gửi lên đấy thôi Nó nào
giống như tim sokute nó chặn việc của
mình là ngon thế nhưng mà chính vì chặn
việc mình đang on là không báo lên hoặc
Facebook là mình đã ngon đấy thì nó lại
có nhược điểm đó là ông sẽ không nhận
được thông báo
Áo kiểu kiểu như thế bởi vì rõ ràng là
ông chặn không bảo thằng Facebook là tao
đang offline thì thằng Facebook nó sẽ
không gửi lại cho ông cái việc là những
cái thông báo mới đến an toàn này tại
tra thì ông mới xem được có thông báo à
Ừ
tí bạn đi xem những Story màng mình chưa
kết bạn đấy
à cái cái cái cái đấy cũng hay thế thôi
mà tôi làm cái vừa nãy ý tôi phải chia
sẻ cùng xem rồi đấy nó không có Sorry
đâu chứ nếu mà có Sony sẽ tôi cũng làm
đấy
à à
ừ ừ
anh nói chung à Cái tune cuối này nó nó
hơi nhạy cảm một tí tôi nói ra ở đây có
gì cũng có một vài bạn nữ sẽ ghét tôi ở
bóc phốt tôi nên tôi sẽ không chia sẻ
rồi Như tôi sẽ chia sẻ với cái này
khi tôi vừa nãy tôi Còn nói tôi Tải hết
ảnh về đúng không ạ
Và tôi nói tôi sẽ lọc những cái ảnh đấy
như cách để cho lọc những cái ảnh đấy
còn cách tôi sẽ làm tôi làm hạt cái tool
này là cảnh như thế này nó kiểu ví dụ
vừa rồi nó nói là thận sóng với mấy nhìn
cái ảnh tao không bị diệt cùng một lúc 6
mấy nghìn cái được thì tôi cần phải xóa
những cái nào tôi đã xóa mà lưu lại
những cái nào tôi đã duyệt không đấy thì
tôi làm cái tôn kiểu như này
ô tô tại hết ảnh về rồi tôi chỉ chọn thư
mục thôi không ạ sẽ chỉ đi ra hết toàn
bộ ảnh sau đó thì mình có thể làm có chế
ra mình tích và những cái ảnh mà mình sẽ
muốn lưu lại và xóa cải nào mình không
tích đúng không ạ
a computing soket không phải do tôi làm
đâu do Anh Tuấn làm đấy Anh đấy Thì đúng
là anh anh ấy chưa khỏi định làm trên
Firefox và tìm hiểu trên đấy mệt mà
anh ấy không phải đấy Tôi làm cơ chế này
nghĩa là tôi sẽ
để duyệt đến một nửa sau tôi ấn nút chọn
đâu chả lạ khi nó sẽ xóa toàn bộ những
cái câu không chọn nhưng mà từ đầu cho
đến cái tôi không trọng chứ không phải
Xóa hết toàn bộ những cái thông trọng
Ừ cái cái lâu rách để nó khá hợp lý mà
thậm chí là cái này vừa rồi các bạn để ý
kĩ kỳ tôi chỉ và ảnh nó còn phóng to
được ảnh lên để mà cậu kiểm tra mụn kiểm
tra gì đó hiểu Xem ảnh Thực sự nghe à
Hồi nãy tội dùng cái tiện ích kỷ mà tải
tải ảnh từ Instagram Ông thấy ở trên à
ở trên thanh địa chỉ của tôi có cái phần
tiện ích à chị nick nó down bung thì
phải sẽ tải toàn bộ ảnh từ trên
Instagram hình Nghĩa hồi đấy là có hỗ
trợ cả Tải ảnh toàn bộ ảnh trên Facebook
cũng có
ừ ừ
à à
Ừ
ok Nói chung là bây giờ cạn 9 giờ rồi
ngoại mình chắc là hôm nay thở ra hơi
nhàm chán một tí vì mình lỡ chia sẻ rất
nhiều về cũng hay hay ở bên đó bên quét
rồi và Xuka à Cũng gần đây cũng chẳng
biết là chia sẻ thêm cái gì mới nữa bởi
vì có rất nhiều vẻ hay nhưng thực sự thì
phải đến theo các bạn đủ lượng kiến thức
nhất định đã mình mới chia sẻ được con
này mình chia sẻ với các bạn
toàn bộ những cái khó khó được nên là
các bạn không Ta không à
không để hay hài hước mãi được
do hôm nay tạm thế đã mình khi vọng mình
nói truyền cảm hứng nữa các bạn một phần
nào đó
chào các bạn nha à
ừ ừ